[Musique]
mais merveille le moment est venu pour
vous après toutes ces péripéties d'aller
voir celui pour lequel nous sommes venus
ici
celui pour lequel nous avons tous fait
des lettres celui pour lequel nous avons
fait des kilomètres et des kilomètres
alors oui on a fait des kilomètres en
avion oui on a fait des kilomètres en
bus et maintenant pour mériter de voir
le père noël
il va falloir faire des kilomètres à
plus ça use
merci les regarde
on va partir dans la forêt pour aller à
la recherche du père noël vous aurez
chacun un kit de survie à savoir dans ce
sac à dos voilà on a trouvé que sa maman
rescue lar
[Rires]
ce sont les sacs sont les faits dans
votre sac vous trouverez des boissons
des chiffes des sandwichs vous trouverez
un kit de survie
d'accord on ira certainement mangé au
sein de la forêt à un moment j'ai à ma
disposition
ici une carte une carte
[Rires]
ça c'est la phalange
d'accord on pense à l'envers
effectivement c'est la finlande ça c'est
mon cul
trois minutes non non vous inquiétez pas
j'ai une carte vous allez me suivre
d'accord si vous avez le droit de soucis
ou lever le bras
j'interviendrai en tant que médecin
soigneur ambulanciers chauffeurs je peux
éventuellement porter quelqu'un les
chéris ça va pas être une partie de
plaisir et je ne rigole pas est ce qu'il
ya des bêtes féroces
il peut y avoir des bêtes féroces c'est
pour cette raison que dans mon sac mais
non je suis harnais 6 armé d'un couteau
de cuisine ou si quelqu'un vous attaque
vous m'appelez et la nave juge avait
juste à crier turlututu chapeau pointu
devenant le cul bon traité j'ai une
carte bancaire
les chéris sachez qu'au bout de ce
périple il y aura si on y arrive
des surprises incroyables dont une
surprise exceptionnel
car voulais absolument faire le plein en
réel puisque je les ai eus au téléphone
encore hier à l'un d'entre vous à l'un
d'entre vous ont ils vraiment dans la
neige lamy il a dit à l'un ou l'autre
des deux fois connais bien mon cyril et
on me dit me parles de ton mari et je me
suis dit oh oh je vais vous donner à
chacun vaut kit de survie
isabelle voilà toute petite tu mets ton
sac à dos isabelle avant de partir s'il
vous plaît il avait ce que tu prêtes à
partir mais évidemment il avec tu mets
ton sac et tu vas rejoindre un des
canaux carreau est ce que tu es prête à
relever le défi et à partir à la
recherche du père noël tu mets ton sac
tu parais tu rejoins des câbles ou
gilles verdez que tu es prêt à relever
le défi plus que jamais
mathieu est ce que tu es prêt à relever
le défi ouais nous cueille mal quelque
chose que je revienne pas ça fait bon
marché
quand ton kit de survie on s'est trompé
ce que tu va relever le défi oui je vais
relever le défi à cartel de boeuf pas
réunies tant que tu le passes tu ne mets
tu le mets
[Musique]
ara haras on y va dans 5 minutes à la
base et tf1
allez voir tf1 explicite
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà on va partir à la recherche du
père noël pour une très longue très
longue randonnée et on va partir on va
nous laisser en pleine euphorie
wae ma carte cinquième nation mystère et
chips mais un paquet de chips et un
couteau avec un paquet de chips un
couteau je peux aller au bout du monde
mais n'arrive un giuly alors vous allez
voir là maintenant on va aller à la
recherche du père noël va tout le
trouver sachez qu'on va partir pour une
randonnée de trois heures avec cette
équipe de croire l'enfer plus quatre
heures je pense a duré quatre heures et
moi car on est parti vivre aux et on est
parti peu d'un pays peut nuit et à un
moment il est très très me regarde
[Musique]
les chéris on va passer par là ok allez
vas-y la vie mettez pas en avant
attention amis à temps c'est bien bravo
va me regarder juste portant basile boli
voilà la belle attitude
bravo jean piché mais moi j'ai le pq
mois les bonnes attitudes poids maxi
voilà la nouvelle escalade en fait déjà
la rando c'est pas du tout mon délire
mais si tout le monde s'y met et me
souffle sur le dos ça va pas le faire
[Musique]
y'a un animateur qui ouvre les batteurs
qui fait la route donc là sera moi au
milieu des chroniques bastia brest parce
que c'est mieux qu'un animateur kiêu et
un autre qui ferme c'est que seuls ceux
qui se sentent pas peuvent dire non à
tout instant ouais
thierry mettez-vous par d'importances
des chroniqueurs les six mois passés à
berchem by matthew je vais petit qui lit
qui veut se mettre devant je pense
qu'elle n'a pas tout compris celle là
déjà dans l'émission elle est derrière
donc dans la randonnée tu vas garder ta
place c'est derrière l'instant celui qui
est juste derrière cyril c'est moi et ça
restera mon tranquille d'accord mais je
commence à me courir sur le haricot
il s'attaque toujours plus faibles il se
met toujours en avant donc si tu veux tu
attaquer aux plus faibles qui passera
moins d'accord ça va mal on tient bon
dans dix minutes je me considère comme
définitivement perdu je sais pas ce que
j'attendais ce qui se passe on est
perdus c'est un nom n'est pas du tout
perdu
et toujours à l'antenne je vérifie je
vérifie chance de fuir quand c'est un
peu plus fins richement d'afro donc là
ça fait juste milan condé dans cette
forêt je vais craquer j'en peux plus
qu'est ce que la falla froid kelly mais
telle une chaufferette la non des alévis
lévis c'était à 24 ans annonçant là les
mecs là là c'est très sain on est on est
sur le bon chemin il faut qu'on aille
par là normalement je me rappelle très
bien de cette arme parce que je suis
direct d'une fois on est on a quelques
kilos mais tu sais où tu as un avis
janadi a tal afar dans la focus a rien à
voir
les deux chroniqueurs n'a pas conscience
de la situation s'ils ne restera pas
juste chroniqueur ça peut être animateur
et leader price en chine qui comme moi
donc ils sont pas content de ce qui se
passe moi je vois cyril quand il
commence à être en over job comme ça
c'est de l'anglais trop de blagues c'est
qu'en fait ils en panique
on va rentrer dans un parcours difficile
de bien refermer la barre moi monsieur
je veillais ch ont fait une fille un
garçon et un garçon et on est parti
[Musique]
on
ans
les amis 320 peu notre ami jean mittal
et faire poser une pêche y est un piège
qu'a ta pièce regardez pas verbe haut et
on peut avoir un peu de victimes et
ouais y'a un connexion avec la nature à
rabaisser un kit bond tout le monde a
l'air de se [ __ ] de ma gueule en tout
cas le seul qui en laponie aura baissé
son futur par -20° est écoulé un bond
dans la neige passé il y voit la joie de
pâques faire des gerçures janvier il en
a l'habitude je fais du bien au sens
plus léger bravo bravo aujourd'hui enfin
bravo jean michel hayat
il n'a pas non plus tu vas aujourd'hui
on va tous à venir quand ça va il a
cogné allez on est reparti des chemins
[Musique]
non mais au secours je vous promets je
tombe encore une fois j'arrête
[Applaudissements]